after being packed and sealed this batch
of sugar is headed to the port india has
already exported a record seven and a
half million tons this season now the
government has capped shipments to
ensure there's enough left over for
domestic consumption get sugarcane alok
sriram's company has been refining sugar
for 90 years he says the new rules could
affect farmers incomes
the sugar season starts in november
and the government would always like a
minimum stock in the country of about
two months
consumption or two and a half months
consumption which is somewhere around
six million tons
it's been a bumper harvest for the
world's top sugar producer international
demand is high sparking fears over
domestic shortage during the festive
season later this year
while high global prices and a strong
dollar have opened up business
opportunities for farmers and traders
soaring inflation and concerns about
food security back home have prompted
the government to implement protective
measures including restricting wheat
exports
wheat farmers such as sanjay bhatia hope
to cash in on a favorable international
market
prices rose after russia's invasion cut
supply from the black sea region but a
scorching heat wave in india threatened
output and the government banned most
exports to control domestic prices
that's affected farmers profits
the government price was higher last
year so we sold them more this time
their rates are lower
wheat production is much lower it kept
raining and there was water logging too
which impacted the harvest
economists say these restrictions do
little to reduce inflation india's
credibility as a reliable exporter
of primary
commodities
is going to be
seriously damaged with this
i don't see this
as a good good signal
al jazeera asked for a government
comment but we didn't get a reply many
countries have urged india to lift its
ban on wheat exports government leaders
say they won't relax the ban but who
will consider requests from vulnerable
countries
well we can speak to pawnee live now uh
in new delhi and pavli what about local
supplies is the ban having any impact
there
so the interesting thing is that
producers point out that the cap the
government has placed on these exports
which is about 10 million tons is much
higher than what they've managed to
export over the last few years and that
much of what was supposed to leave the
shores has already left and they
understand that this is more of a
preventative measures but there are
concerns in terms of loss in business
opportunity because for the first time
in a while the international market
both in terms of demand and prices were
stronger
than it had been in a while and so there
are worries that the profits that are to
trickle down to the indian farmer could
be smaller economists though are more
concerned about the signal the uh
restriction on the wheat exports uh will
have both domestically and
internationally
again the wheat market domestically has
been traditionally stronger but the
government was really keen to cash in on
the strong dollar and the rise in demand
and prices internationally and so when
this
ban came about it sort of shocked a lot
of people and there was a lot of panic
on ground there was chaos there were
trucks that were stuck at ports and
eventually the government had to make
some exceptions
now economists point out that these are
policies especially the one regarding
wheat that will do little to solve the
inflation issue back in india you know
inflation is still very high the latest
numbers came in in terms of gdp growth
for the quarter of jan to march the
economy grew at just about four percent
which is the slowest in a while but
economists say that instead the
government needs to uh you know
formulate policies that incentivize
farmers to keep a food produce here
while making sure their incomes are not
hit
pablo thanks very much indeed for that
paving mitel there reporting from new
delhi